you know what it is [ __ ] thug notes
and this week we keepin it epic with Oh
massage
[Applause]
gettin real up in the kingdom of it King
Odysseus been gone for almost 20 years
and even his son Telemachus and sexy
wife Penelope ain't heard a peep about
where yet since everybody figured he did
a hundred an egg Shady hustlers star
macking on Penelope so they can get a
crack at some of that royal poontang and
crowned himself King apparently Odysseus
been stuck on some Island where he's
been pussy-whipped by the goddess
Calypso who been all up on his junk but
all the gods up in Mount Olympus tell
Calypso she gotta take Odysseus off the
short leash so he can get his ass home
Odysseus set sail for Ithaca but the sea
God beside and got a stick up his ass
and drop some nasty storm on my boy old
he shakes off that hater and with the
help of the gods makes it to the shore
of fire where he starts vibing with the
king and queen bout his travels he tells
him about the time he punked a cyclops
named Polyphemus Odysseus told this fool
that his name is nobody get some crazy
drunk that shakes him and I when he's
passed the [ __ ] out so now the
Polyphemus say that nobody has blinded
me all the other cyclopses be all like
what you yapping bout man turns out the
Cyclops he wrecked actually be
Poseidon's son and the god of the sea is
all blood heard about so that's the
reason it's taking Odysseus almost 10
years to get home from the Trojan War
finally Odysseus makes it back to Ithaca
and with Athena's help disguises himself
as a nasty hobo later
Penelope decides she's gonna give
herself to whoever could string or
dismiss his bow and shoot an arrow from
12 axe heads after Odysseus wins the
contest like a boss he reveals himself
to everybody then he calls straight post
on all them haters tryin to get freaky
with his woman once Odysseus done
stacking bodies the people be all like
Odysseus
what the man so just when the busy is
about to start messing again Athena
steps in and tells everybody chill baby
I don't want no drama thanks to the gods
it's because that piece doing the nasty
with banging goddesses laying the whoop
on side classicist and sticking it to
all-powerful divine beings ain't no
thang for Odysseus cuz every day he us
now ain't only the muscle that giving
Odysseus true OG status he also got mad
street smarts whenever some fool steps
up the old dision he able to do come by
line his ass off and rockin different
disguises for example by giving the
Cyclops a fake name and dressing like a
hobo when he back in Ithaca be able to
get the jump on all his enemies folktale
players call this motif the trickster
but even someone as hardcore as Odysseus
ain't always in the driver's seat cuz
sometimes he's behind the wheel but
other times he's riding [ __ ] and the
gods whip this brings me to one of the
poems main themes is the gods for the
best happens on earth I race humanity
responsible for that mess heed this
quote from Big Daddy Zeus the king of
the gods
mortals they're always blaming the gods
for their troubles when their own
witless nough scauses them more than
they were destined for who's to blame
for old Diddy being gone for so long was
it his own doing since he blinded beside
and son I was beside and just being a
seriously backwards dude
now you can't flow about Odysseus
without getting the lowdown on the story
of Agamemnon who also try to get his
self home after the Trojan War set when
he got there he found his woman hiding
dad with some other player who straight
ghost in his ass but lucky for this is
his woman ain't like that he got one of
the fly his biddies on the plant who
slays her own brand of trickery she says
she can't shack up with no sucker
so she done weaving some cloth but every
night she undoes what she did during the
day this Fox manages to keep these cats
in line for 10 whole years while
dizziest strives to get his ass home and
it's that righteous in doors that make
her just as heroic as old is he
himself so if there's one thing that
Penelope Athena and other ladies proved
is that even a Greek hero as bad as
Odysseus ain't doing without a woman you
know thanks for watching thug notes
subscribe check out my other videos and
tune in next week homeboy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]